fighters from the people's Defense Force
embargo Central Myanmar fire at
government troops in late November if
2021 was dominated by Street protests
2022 was the year of armed struggle
loose plans of Fighters opposed to the
military coup have attacked soldiers
across the country even in areas the
Army considered safe
the ethnic time groups that have fought
myanmar's government for decades now see
an opportunity we need more coordination
to Amanda other groups at that side in
downtown we are trying hard for it just
only three four five groups that we were
together in in the moment but in the
future we do believe that there will
come in together with us and so fight
against the military
but the consequences have been dire
myanmar's military is accused of
implying a policy of scorched Earth
torching areas where it detects
resistance he does crying Against
Humanity in World crime
for example military has been Banning
thousands of houses of the civilians
killing many innocent people by
asteroids
and that's one place the military have
complete control the skies
airstrikes are taking place on a daily
basis
more than a million people have fled
their homes and live in remote jungle
camps without sanitation or basic
facilities
in the past these steep mountains in
Myanmar provided a buffer zone stopping
the conflict from spilling over into
Thailand but in the last 12 months
myanmar's military has been using
fighter jets and attack helicopters
forcing the conflict right up to the
Border
the borders slowly opened up after the
pandemic but little traffic is going
across the military government imposed
currency controls and restrictions on
investment that have stifled economic
growth this yangon-based businessman
fled after his assets were confiscated
by the military now he makes a meager
living selling noodles and tea online
as a businessman wherever you can find
money you do business but if I lost my
dignity I couldn't get it back therefore
I will stand for the truth and I will
keep my dignity
Myanmar looks increasingly cut off from
the outside
country and paralysis moving backwards
rather than Fords the progress of the
past decade has stalled there appear to
be troubled waters ahead Tony Chang Al
Jazeera Myanmar